يبدو ان للرجال سنا للياس ايضا ومكان
يعتقد انه حكرا على النساء يدخله الرجال
ايضا سن الياس يفتكبر رجال وبقوه العمر
يمضي وهذا الوباء الصامت يقتحم حياه
الرجال الذين يتجاوزون منتصف اعمارهم
التقديريه لتتغير الكثير من التفاصيل
الحياتيه بالنسبه لهم يفقد الرجال كثيرا
من هرمون التستوستيرون بنسبه كبيره في هذه
المرحله وهو ضائف الجسم تصبح اقل
ديناميكيه هذا تراجع يدفع رجال الى شباب
اقل يفقد الجسم قدرته على حرق الدهون
وتزيد التجاعيد ما معها يصبح رجال اكثر
عرضه للاكتئاب
ايام صلاح عيني طالع مرتبطه بالنساء لكن
يبدو انه مرض صامت يصيب ملايين رجال حول
العالم هل هذا فعلا
في الموضوع وليس مجرد وصف خلينا نقول عام
او شعبي لا في شيء يحدث عند الرجل الفرق
يمكن الجوهري يعني ما يحدث بين الرجل
المراه من عند المراه بيكون واضح وبشكل
واضح جدا بمعنى الوقت قصير جدا لحدوث سن
الياس عند الرجل الموضوع على فترات فبيبدا
التناقص من بعد الاربعين نبلش نشوف انه في
اختلاف في هرمون الذكوره ونبلش نشوف في
اختلاف باشياء اخرى همم الوزن طبعا
الاصابات في بعض الامراض اللي ممكن نحكي
عنها
محمد يعني لماذا لابحاث النفسيه والدراسات
محدوده وضئيله في ما يتعلق بسن لا الياس
للرجال فيما للنساء يعني مفصله ومشوه يعني
هل في عدم جديه في التعامل مع المسلمين
جسديه واضحه بنكون فاهمينها يعني احنا ما
نتكلم عن مثلا انا في علم النفس بنحكي عن
الوسواس القهري هذا تشخيص واضح بس لما
نتكلم عن اكتئاب قلق او قلق بشكل عام وعام
هون طب ما هو اي احد ممكن يبين عليه انه
قلق وبين انه في نفس الشيء في ما يخصني
اسال نعم فيه اعراض تصبح واضحه يعني سواء
شكليه جسديه عند الرجل او في سلوكه يعني
القلق والميل للاكتئاب همم الميل همم بعض
العادات اليوميه الكسوله يعني الكسل
المرتبط جدا بسن الياس عند الرجال هلا
فعليا لو جئنا تفرجنا على كثير من الرجال
بعد الاربعين وال 45 50 ممكن لا انه والله
التشخيص واضح
يعني على المراه يؤثر على قدرتها على
الانشاء بالنسبه للرجل يؤثر عليه شكليا
ونفسيا يعني يكون عنده قلق واكتئاب بحسب
الدراسات وفقدان بعض الشعر وكذلك يمكن
السمنه لكن لا يؤثر على قدرته بالانجاب
لماذا
هذا الموضوع كثير دقيق لانه حتى القدره
على الانجاب بيصير في تاثر لكن اذا اخذنا
من ناحيه الاداء من ناحيه راح يصير فيه
تاثر واضح جدا عند الرجل في العلاقه
العاطفيه وايضا يعني مستوى الافراز
الهرمونات المرتبطه بالذكوره نعم تتاثر بس
انه بيصير الموضوع همم ما زال يمكن هذا
الموضوع طبي اكثر لكن ما زال يمكن همم عند
الرجل القيام
يصيب الرجل القلق واكتئاب
يعني بنتكلم عن اعراض جسديه واعراض نفسيه
نتكلم عن تعرق الكرش ببلش يبين همم بشكل
واضح يعني بتلاقي بصير فيه
ممكن يعني بدناش نبالغ بس انه في نسبح بس